[Music]
one of the things we know about
motivation is that we're able to trigger
those parts of our neurology that are
related to motivating us when we feel in
control and very frequently this comes
from making a choice some something that
allows us to assert ourselves into a
situation one of the most fascinating
examples of this is how the Marine Corps
revamped basic training so about 15
years ago the Marine Corps founded was
having this problem they were getting a
bunch of recruits that were coming in
who were completely unprofessional
they they essentially had never learned
the skills of this now for the Marine
Corps this is a real problem because the
Marines are kind of different from other
branches of the military they're usually
the first in and the last to leave and
so what they need is they need real
self-starters people who know how to
take the initiative
but the recruits are coming through the
door to boot camp we're just completely
in practice in this Charles croolik who
is the head of the Marine Corps told me
that a lot of these recruits had never
been on sports teams they had never
learned how to assert themselves they
had never practiced self motivation so
Krulak looked at the literature and he
found that there were a bunch of studies
that said the most effective Marines are
ones who have learned an internal locus
of control
we all have an internal or external
locus of control and what that means is
it's how we see the world whether we
believe that we have the ability to
assert ourselves and control our
destinies or whether we believe that the
things that happen around us determine
whether we're successful or not
Krulak wanted to teach his recruits how
to have an internal locus of control
what in the Marines they call a bias
towards action and so he redesigned
route bootcamp completely it now when
people enter boot camp instead of
learning discipline and learning how to
follow orders which is how most of us
think about it that's the cliche instead
they're trained on making decision after
decision after decision taking control
and asserting themselves in ways that
maybe they didn't even expect they would
need to at the end of boot camp is this
thing called the crucible it's a 56 hour
obstacle course that every recruit has
to complete in order to become a Marine
and during the crucible what's really
interesting is some of the obstacles
only be completed if you kind of disobey
the orders you're hearing one of my
favorite is this thing called sergeant
Timmerman's tank where you have to use
these ropes and logs to move across this
big sandpit and you're told not to do
anything unless you get a direct order
from your platoon leader but the thing
is everyone's wearing gas masks you
can't hear your platoon leader and your
platoon leader is wearing a gas mask
whatever he shouts nobody can make out
the only way to actually do the obstacle
is if everyone pretends that they're
listening to their platoon leader and
sort of self-organizes on the fly now we
don't think of the Marines or we don't
think of the military as some place that
teaches us to be subversive but this is
the biggest insight is that when people
feel the subversive instinct when they
feel this need to take control and
assert themselves that's when they learn
how to generate self motivation and the
more that we can give that to kids or
co-workers the more that we can
encourage it in our self that feeling
that you're on the freeway and you're
stuck in a traffic jam and you want to
just take that exit because it feels so
good to be in control
that's where motivation comes from so
anyone can learn a bias towards action
in fact it's something that we can learn
at any stage in life one of my favorite
studies
about motivation comes from this
examination of how nursing homes work
and why some people succeed in nursing
homes and other people sort of just get
old and pass away and what they found is
the people who are most successful in a
nursing home setting are the ones who
tried to break the rules so one of my
favorite examples is that they were
talking to a group of nursing home
residents in Santa Fe and they found
that on the most the people who lived
the longest who sort of did best once
they were in the nursing home was this
group of seniors who as soon as they got
their meal tray from the cafeteria where
the the nursing home would tell them you
should have this to eat and that to eat
they would trade among themselves and
kind of make their own meals and they
talked to this one guy and he said that
he always traded away his chocolate cake
and that he actually loved chocolate
cake but that he would rather eat a meal
of his own creation then just placidly
take what was been being handed to him
and that's actually why he was
successful in the nursing home is
because people who look for ways to
prove to themselves that they're in
control whether they're in control of
their own life or whether they're in
control of their own decisions those are
the people who manage to motivate to
exercise more and to keep up
relationships with friends and to
partake in the community the subversive
instinct if you can encourage that then
you learn how to self motivate and it
just pays these huge dividends in your
life
[Music]